hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my cloak-and-dagger video I know
there's lots of questions about where
this falls relative to the finger snap
so I'll try to explain that
Jeff lobe from Marvel has explained
we're pretty much all the TV series fall
relative to the snap sure obviously
spoiler warning if you haven't seen it
yet but they debuted during a spider-man
title it was Peter Parker the
spectacular spider-man number 64 so
under most circumstances they'd be
popping up in New York City but Jeph
Loeb who handles all the Marvel TV
series basically said that the snap sure
is happening after all these TV series
all six stones are Kazuto snapped my
fingers
there was no other way Wendy I'm gay now
okay so when you see all this stuff
happening in the flashbacks this is
really like the early 2000s because she
whips her flip phone out so that kind of
helps date the series a little bit so
it's really like an untouched period in
the Marvel Universe because you have
Captain Marvel stuff happening in the
90s you have ant-man the wasp stuff that
was happening back during the 80s but
the big thing they want to let you know
is that they're just completely messed
up and I think you know part of the
ideas is that they'll help make each
other whole because the creator of the
characters said that the whole idea
behind the two of them is that they're
supposed to embody all these ideas of
fear misery hunger and longing so like
when they come together they'll make
each other better
so in the way that opposites attract
like they had a really big twist at the
end of episode 2 like they keep finding
each other through really weird
circumstances but really they spend the
first two episodes just sort of setting
the scene letting you know what's going
on with the characters what their damage
is like I love the way that they make
Tandi the really crazy one that Tyrone
did go off the rails during episode two
when he went after his one-arm man so to
speak with the gun like he has the man
with the scar that killed his brother
that he's gonna be pursuing for what
seems like the rest of the series
we have Rock's incorporation and then we
have the origin of their powers so they
have changed a couple things from the
comics but if it wasn't clear this is
all happening in New Orleans so it's
basically a new area of the Marvel
Universe that we haven't really seen on
a TV series before so it's a little
easier to explain like why spider-man
isn't swinging by if he was such a big
part of their original debut in the
comics but you have to imagine that this
is happening relatively close to
present-day like daredevil Luke Cage all
the Netflix series are all happening
relatively close to present-day
but right before the snap sure the way
they opened with the ballet though that
is a comic book thing but being a ballet
dancer is a big part of Tandi Bowens
origin story in the comics before she
got her powers so she and Tyrone in the
comics got their abilities through this
special experiment there was sort of a
medical basis for it so they're not
technically mutants but they draw their
power from the dark force and most of
you probably saw that when you saw the
rocks and
finery sort of collapse in on itself
like hey wait a minute that kind of
looks like the thing from agent Carter
which is basically what they're doing so
way back in the 40s during agent Carter
the rocks and corporation was
experimenting they found the dark force
by accident the way that Tyrone talks
about poison is actually a literal thing
like the dark force can actually poison
you but he finds a way to cleanse
himself of that via Tandy so you kind of
see what's going on here the whole thing
with the light daggers is that yeah she
can stab people with them but her light
force which is sort of like the polar
opposite to the dark force can purify
people of poisons and toxins so for
Tyrone that becomes a psychological
thing but it's also a literal thing too
like if you're literally poison she can
help heal you pretty much a parade of
WTF through the first couple of episodes
though like they just want to let you
know how hard up they are so you see her
snorting pills in the abandoned church
the church is right out of the comics
but the pills is a new thing I think
they just want you to know that she's
doing painkillers that it seems like she
found at that rich dudes house they also
do a good job of letting you know that
they both been screwed over by their
circumstances in Tyrone's case it's the
police cover-up in this like you know
literal bad person that seems like he's
a vice cop who has a mysterious uncle
who we may find has ties to Roxon who at
least initially is just the villain of
Tandy's story because her father was a
scientist at rocks and probably
experimenting on the dark force trying
to study it before things went crazy so
his big corporations do they sort of
railroad her and her mom after her
father's death it becomes this big
analogy for the Exxon Valdez big oil
spill like big natural disaster let's
blame it on the guy that just died I
think they made it pretty clear though
that the police are probably in bed with
Roxon or at least in roxxon's pocket so
we haven't really met who the actual big
villain is going to be the man with the
scar the tyrone keeps unconsciously
teleporting to is probably just
somebody's Lackey so that person will
probably manifest by the end of the
season just for reference there supposed
to be ten episodes total so obviously
because the first two aver there's gonna
be eight more episodes after this so
eight more weeks of cloak-and-dagger as
far as I know I don't think
gonna be any breaks in the way that they
air the episodes they haven't quite
figured out how their powers work like
that's probably gonna be another episode
or two with them just like slowly
playing with things like Tandy can't
control her light yet and you can kind
of see that there's a cost to her light
daggers it leaves an exit wound on her
hand so she does bleed a little bit but
the funny thing about Tyrone's
teleporting is is that it seems like he
needs darkness to teleport like he can
only teleport when he's running from the
man with the scar when he crawls
underneath that black tarp so if you
watched other series like the gifted
they have like two twins that sort of
have this synergistic ability when they
come together they give off what they
call the Fenris force also something
from Marvel Comics but I'm curious to
see if they're going to change that for
the cloak and dagger series like their
powers do kind of work together but they
mostly help each other it's not like
they amplify each other's abilities
they've changed the way their
backstories and their powers work a
little bit in the comics it used to be
that his cloak helped him teleport but
here it's more like a mutant ability
where he just gives it off naturally but
like I said it does seem like he needs a
form of Darkness to be able to do it so
like he has to crawl underneath his bed
sheet in order to be able to teleport
but for maybe the next couple of
episodes he's still gonna be doing it
unconsciously he just wakes up in the
man's trunk like how the hell did I get
here what the hell is going on I'm just
gonna throw this bag of coke in his face
and run away the thing you have to
remember about Tandy - because she's not
in school so it doesn't date her quite
as much is that she's about the same age
is Tyrone so they're like maybe he's 17
18 years old maybe closer to 17 so all
the stuff that she does like she has
this weird codependent relationship with
this other grifter while they're
stealing stuff trying to hook up with
really rich dudes so she can steal their
stuff taking drugs drinking all this is
happening while she's still in high
school so like the actress looks like
she's quite a bit older so it's kind of
hard to tell but they're kind of using
Tyrone's high school storylines to
anchor that like oh yeah these are
actually really young kids while this is
all going on but in the comics most of
the time when they pop up they're much
much older they're like late 20s early
30s when you see Tyrone touches mother
and go into that weird mind space and
watch
nightmare that's actually something from
the comics - so when he teleports he
goes into the Dark Dimension and then
exits at the different point but while
his powers are active it also sort of
releases the worst nightmares of the
people that he's with so when he's
talking to the Reverend about poisoning
the man that poisoned him like maybe he
should be poisoned like me he can
actually do that literally like he'd
actually be able to drive this man
insane with his grief like when his
mother goes into that nightmare like she
probably saw what he saw but she's so
good at suppressing it that you just
don't see it on her face like she just
pretends like it didn't happen so like I
said that's where Tandy comes in like
she can sort of cleanse him of that
darkness but like it literally poisons
people so when he's talking about it
it's not just a metaphor but I think the
arc of the series is pretty clear like
first they learn about their powers they
learn about their relationship with each
other they're like oh you're the person
from that accident from the beach and
she knows like she's just pretending not
to know then them dealing with the
external forces like Tyrone dealing with
this man that killed his brother and
then Tandy dealing with Roxon with the
help of Tyrone like she probably won't
be able to do it by herself they
obviously have a couple of seasons of
this plan so they're not gonna bring
rocks and tumbling down like they're a
billion-dollar oil company so it's not
like they're gonna go away overnight but
the next big step is just finding out
who the person at Roxon is that's
ordering all this experimentation on the
dark force that sort of orchestrated all
of the big cover-ups but that's also
where you get into the police well you
know we had like this new police female
character that seems like she's a
relatively good person who will probably
find out what's going on with Tandy then
once she finds out that they're not the
bad guys try to help them out but like
for now Tandy is still wanted by the law
because she's been doing very very
illegal stuff like probably one of my
favorite moments in the first two
episodes is where like her friend that
she's been with for all those years
helping her grift people calls her and
says I've been pinched I need your help
and she basically just hangs up like
screw you I'm out of here then BAM Oh
karma comes back around as Tyrone who
was trying to kill the man with the scar
accidentally
ports to the road right in front of her
Omo shooting her in the face
karma will bite you in the ass but
that's not really what's going on I
think they just want to let you know
that they're not gonna be able to get
too far apart from each other but if
you're wondering why it is Tyrone
teleported when he pulled the trigger or
when he was getting ready to it was just
because he was having so much cognitive
dissonance like he's a good person so
his mind was starting to snap like oh my
god I'm getting ready to kill somebody
and the reason why he keeps mysteriously
teleporting to Tandy and this man with a
scar is because he's thinking about them
unconsciously it seems like they're kind
of on a similar timeline so by the time
he figures out how to control his
teleporting Tandy will figure out how to
control her light daggers and her light
force so Tandy's light force is sort of
like the lightning rod for Tyrone when
he gets lost inside the dark force which
is a separate dimension not to be
confused with the dark hold from agents
of shield so couple big concepts the
dark force dimension the dark dimension
which is a completely different thing
that's Doctor Strange Dormammu not the
same thing as the dark force dimension
then the dark hold which was a book of
magic written by a demon from another
dimension so you sort of have a lot of
dr. strange magic ideas bleeding over
into the Marvel TV universe but just let
me know what you thought of the series
so far I'm willing to do videos for the
other episodes just depending on
interest level my voice is a little
hoarse right now so it should be better
by the time there are more episodes but
what'll happen later today is there was
some new Marvel Avengers ant-man the
wasp footage that drops so I'll do a
video for that but leave all your video
requests in the comments below click
here for brand new infinity war and
click here to learn all about when Young
Justice season 3 and Titans are gonna
premiere in that new streaming service
that DC is doing
you